looks a bit like a yo-yo
that's quite cool but yeah I've never oh
God
looks like dog poo look
[Music]
[Applause]
hi guys I'm Marcus Smith and this is
snack Wars UK vs New Zealand on sport
Bible
twiglet and twisties
and Granddad loves Penguins so shout out
to my Grandad big penguin fan
[Music]
um these New Zealand ones they are the
New Zealand ones they got better um
packaging than us that's for sure if
they get they get points for that this
one versus that one the twiglets one's
pretty boring
tastes like
I like dissolve in your mouth cheesy
not too cheesy though and also I like
the fact it's bigger bag as well so um
okay no wonder them uh kiwi boys eat a
lot of crisps and chips as they like to
call them
twiglets
it's like my mighty I think you're a
Marmite fan no I'm not the biggest fan
no
not for me going again though
yeah I want more just for just for luck
but twisties wins
bloody mama in it
oh gosh
so we got it's a Vegemite oh it's called
Marmite and it's Vegemite in Australia I
think vegemite's Australia that's the
thing just give it a go
my Auntie loves Marmite but
foreign
that's awful what does it taste of to
you
it's just extremely aggressive on the
mouth for a morning
dish I don't know how you could wake up
I know my breath probably won't be
smelling too good
will you wait till you try the next next
option we got here The Gentleman's
Relish not even open this not open
there's like a oh anchovies
what'd you think of that packaging I
think it's quite cool I've never seen it
um seen it before
um looks a bit like a yo-yo quite cool
but yeah I've never oh God
it's like dog poo look
a little bit
[Music]
doesn't look too appetizing on the bread
give it a go
[Music]
[Applause]
wow
that is awful
whoever buys this and enjoys it he's got
something wrong with the taste buds
um it's got to be marmite
oh chocolate covered marshmallow fish as
kiwi as well they got flip-flops on them
I think it's meant to be meant to be
kiwi as the flip-flops because in
Australia we say thongs I'm not sure
what they say in New Zealand as kiwi has
the flip-flops the Cadbury chocolate
fish
so is it going to be shaped as a
flip-flop or a fish or a fish
oh yeah
looks like a looks like a fish
slightly melted so it's a bit wobbly but
do you know what type of fish that is
what would you say I'm gonna guess
looks like every type of fish though
it's not a shark not a shark it's not a
dolphin it is a snapper nice good choice
yeah I think that's right yeah yeah
cheers so I'm gonna eat this snapper
fish
tail first
that's nice what's the flavor inside so
they've got marshmallow inside so it's a
nice pink
marshmallow I quite like marshmallows
especially
burn them and toast them on the fire I
quite like fish as well so you know it's
perfect snack for me a chocolate fish
yeah see bounties
um
not not the biggest fan of bounties my
mum adores Bounty she's
from Philippines so she loves her
coconuts
um stuff like that
I'm not really
that Keen on
eating coconut
weird texture
[Music]
no
and I don't like them little bits that
you're getting with coconut
um
tastes a bit like rubbery in your mouth
no sorry sorry England but the um
chocolate fish wins
[Laughter]
lovely
Old Speckled Hen
very English I think
um
I haven't had a beer in a few weeks so
uh this might hit me cheers
yeah it's too bitter for me
I normally uh I normally go for either
ciders or straight on the hard stuff
um
Disaronno and Coke so we got here a
Spates uh gold medal ale so
give this a try
looks quite dark as well bitter
yeah again
I think let me try this again
yeah it's got to be spikes slightly
lighter on the mouth
I'm not a big bitter drinker so anything
that doesn't taste too much like bitter
I quite like so yeah Spates so another
point for the New Zealand oh lovely
so we got some
elacombe English quality
sparkling wine
straight out the bottle
it's always nice when you get a bottle
of champagne because you think you've
won something
so yeah it's a nice celebration when you
start popping it and celebrating good
memories always comes from a good bottle
of champagne so
really nice not to um
not too fizzy so it doesn't get you the
back of your throat
um
yeah it's quite nice you could drink
that quite quickly as well
you've got your Oyster Bay New Zealand
sauvignon blanc 2021 Edition
never had Oyster Bay before
is it a nice Bay I think it's a nice Bay
yeah full of oysters apparently I love
oysters
I love oysters so I'm probably like this
Oyster Bay white wine
yeah that's nice as well quite smooth
for a white wine but
it's still a bit um
I don't like the acidic taste in the
back of the throat so
which I guess is probably why I don't
like white wine but I like home white
wine wins for me uh New Zealand one
ah what
rugby is better than American football
three two well I'm biased I mean I oh
this is like Rugby Union this is a
traditional rugby I grew up with it I
didn't grow up with American football